SENATOR WILKES BILL.
SB TWO ZERO TWO DEALING WITH
ANIMAL BLOOD DONORS.
AND SENATOR BEFORE YOU BEGAN
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
MET WITH THE CALVET CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REGARDING THE USE OF THE TERM
GUARDIAN THROUGHOUT THE BILL.
AND THAT YOU'RE TAKING
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD REPLACE
THE WORD GUARDIAN WITH THE OWNER.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
AND YOU'VE AGREED TO TAKE THIS
IS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TODAY.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
GO AHEAD PRESENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
LIKE WHAT.
ARE WE CAN SKIP THAT PART
BECAUSE I AM GONNA TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS.
SO SB TWO OH TWO IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT HEALTHY
AND BOUNTIFUL BLOOD SUPPLY FOR
ANIMALS IS AVAILABLE ACROSS THE
STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY FACING A
SHORTAGE OF ANIMAL BLOOD
PRODUCTS IN THE STATE NEEDS TO
HELP TO ENSURE THE WELL BEING OF
OUR ANIMALS AND PETS.
SB TWO OH TWO CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW TO ALLOW FOR THE LICENSURE
COMMUNITY BASED ANIMAL BLOOD
BANKS.
AMBIGUITY IN THE CURRENT CODE IS
LEAD TO MORE LIMITED REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK.
ALLOWING ONLY FOR THE COMMERCIAL
USE OF BLOOD FROM -- CLOSED
COLONY BANKS WHICH KEEP DOGS AND
CATS HOUSE OF FOR YEARS ON THEIR
PREMISES TO TO EXTRACT THEIR
BLOOD.
WELL THESE BLOOD BANKS PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S VETERINARIAN.
VETERINARIAN MEDICAL WORLD.
MAKING ALLOWANCES FOR COMMUNITY
ANIMAL DONORS AS WELL WILL HELP
INCREASE THE BLOOD SUPPLY.
AND ENSURE THAT BOTH ANIMALS AND
FAMILIES PROSPER BY HAVING THESE
PETS IN THEIR IN THEIR HOMES
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE ANIMAL
OWNERS TO VOLUNTEER THEIR DOGS
AND CATS. FOR BLOOD DONATIONS.
UNDER THE OVERSIGHT OF A
LICENSED MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL.
WE HAVE DISCUSSES PROBE PROPOSAL
AT LENGTH WITH EXISTING ANIMAL
BLOOD BANKS AND WE ARE RECEPTIVE
TO THEIR CONCERNS AND AND
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO DIALOGUE
ON STICKING ISSUES.
LOOK.
FOR BOARD WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN REACHING A GOAL
THAT SUITS EVERYONE IN BENEFITS
THE ENTIRE ANIMAL COMMUNITY.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DOCTORS
KAREN HALOGEN. TO PRESENT
TESTIMONY YEAH HI I'M DOCTOR
HALOGEN I GRADUATED FROM UC
DAVIS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE SO
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING THIRTY
YEARS.
I'M CURRENTLY THAT CHEAP THAT
OFFICER FOR THE LUCY PET
FOUNDATION AND WE PROVIDE FREE
SPIN NEUTER SERVICES AND
WELLNESS FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE CITY OF LA.
I ALSO SERVED ON THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS BOARD IN LOS ANGELES
FOR SIX YEARS.
AND I AM CURRENTLY ON THE BOARD
OF SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION WHICH IS THE PROUD
SPONSOR.
OF SB.
TWO OH TWO CALIFORNIA IS THE
ONLY STATE IN THE NATION.
THAT DOES NOT ALLOW COMMUNITY
BASED ALLIED BANK.
AND THERE'S ONLY TWO COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT PROVIDE THIS
LIFESAVING BLOOD.
OR CATS AND DOGS TO COMPANIES.
I BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR THIS
MONOPOLY TO END.
AND YOU NEED TO OPEN THE MARKET
SO WHAT THAT'S GOING TO DO IS
THAT'S GOING TO ALLOW.
AT ITS CAN ALLEVIATE THE
SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
SEEING BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE
WAIT TIME IS CRITICAL FOR AN
ANIMAL IT GETS HIT BY A CAR AND
IT'S BLEEDING NOW.
WE NEED BLOOD HE HAS AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASE IT'S DYING RIGHT THERE
IN FRONT OF YOUR EYES WE NEED
BLOOD.
I EIGHTY THE DOG EATS RAT POISON
AND THEY'RE BLEEDING OUT THERE
SO MANY TIMES THAT WE NEED BOOD
AND THERE'S A CURRENT SHORTAGE.
BECAUSE AS I SAID THERE'S ONLY
TWO COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE FOR
US.
I'M AT THAT THE POSSIBILITIES
ARE ENDLESS INCLUDING I SEE LIKE
THE AMERICAN RED CROSS MOBILE
BLOOD BANKS -- THAT'S GONNA
ALLOW HUGE INCREASE OF BLOOD TO
VETERINARIANS CATS AND DOGS.
IN CALIFORNIA SO.
SB TWO OH TWO IS GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT'S IT'S GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA DOGS AND CATS AND
IT'S GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA.
HAD OWNERS TO PLEASE VOTE YES IN
SUPPORT SB.
TWO OH TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE OTHERWISE -- MY
SECOND WITNESS HERE THIS IS
DOCTOR HAD THE RALLY TO PROVIDE
JUST PLEASE.
THANK YOU WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS HEATHER RALLY I'M A
CALIFORNIA BASED VETERINARIAN
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS EXCLUSIVELY ON
ANIMAL WELFARE ISSUES.
AS THE SUPERVISING VETERINARIAN
FOR THE PIZZA FOUNDATION -- I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL TWO
OH TWO THIS BILL WOULD OPEN UP A
NEW FRONTIER FOR VETERINARY
BUSINESS AND IT WOULD ALSO HELP
CREATE A MORE ROBUST AND
RELIABLE SUPPLY OF LIFESAVING
BLOOD PRODUCTS. FOR DOGS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND.
THIS BILL IS IN MY OPINION LOOKS
REALLY A WIN FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED FROM MY VETERINARY
COLLEAGUES AND OUR PATIENTS. TO
THE OWNERS WHO DEPEND UPON US TO
PROVIDE THE BEST VETERANS ARE
POSSIBLE TO THEIR BELOVED PETS
TO THE DONOR DOGS THEMSELVES.
MEET ANY BLOOD BANKS ARE VIABLE
AND INDEED ARE LITERALLY
THRIVING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW.
IN THESE BUSINESSES HEALTHY
DONOR DOGS WHO LIVE IN LOVING
HOMES ARE VOLUNTEERED BY THEIR
GUARDIANS. TO PROVIDE BLOOD FOR
DOGS IN NEED.
THESE DOGS AND THEIR OWNERS
BENEFIT FROM RECEIVING --
PREVENTATIVE HEALTH CARE AND
ROUTINE HEALTH SCREENINGS OFTEN
AT LOWER NO COST.
AND THEN RECIPIENT DOGS A
VETERINARIANS BENEFIT FROM THE
AVAILABILITY OF SAFE AND
RELIABLE BLOOD PRODUCTS.
WHICH ARE ALL TOO OFTEN IN SHORT
SUPPLY I'M IN CALIFORNIA.
EVERY SINGLE DOG DESERVE TO LIVE
IN A LOVING HOME.
AND EVERY SINGLE DOES NOT A DOG
DESERVES THE BEST VETERINARY
CARE POSSIBLE THIS IS BOTH
ACHIEVABLE -- THIS IS ACHIEVABLE
AND QUITE SIMPLE AND WE PLEASE
WE WOULD LIKE FOR YOU FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB TO A TWO THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI I'M JUDY MAY INCLUSO FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT AS SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY GROUP AND
COCOA.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
GOOD MORNING SUSAN MADDEN ACT
LIKE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WERE
WITH CONCERNS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MA'AM
JERRY AND OF SHARED WILL MIKE
DILLON REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN THAT -- TWEENER
POSITION WE APPRECIATE VERY VERY
MUCH THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR
WILK AGREEING TO TAKE OUT OF THE
WORD GUARDIAN.
AND WITH THESE AMENDMENTS -- WE
COMPLETELY REMOVE OPPOSITION AND
OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS MEETS
THIS WEEKEND AND THEY WILL BE
TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION BUT AS
AMENDED WE THINK THE BILL AS A
VERY POSITIVE STEP IN ALLOWING
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
COMMUNITY SOURCED.
I BANKS AND THE WHILE STILL
ALLOWING THE TWO EXISTING BLOOD
BANKS TO CONTINUE THEIR
OPERATIONS ARE VETERINARIAN FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT COMPLETING
SHUTTING THEM DOWN WOULD BE.
A REAL PROBLEM AND SO ALLOWING
IT -- TO TO GO FORWARD WE THINK
IS A POSITIVE STEP THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHAT BRIEFLY ****
GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL BLOOD BANK -- ANIMAL
BLOOD BANK IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
COMMUNITY SOURCED BLOOD BANKING
IN FACT THEY OPERATE A COMMUNITY
SOURCED BLOOD BANK IN MICHIGAN --
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OF BLOOD NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
WERE COMMUNITY FORCED BLOOD
BANKS OPERATE SO WE WELCOME --
QUALITY BLOOD TO THE MARKET.
I'M WILL DO OUR BEST TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS.
A WE DO HAVE THREE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL PRINCIPALLY THAT --
THE CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTION
THAT EXISTS IN IN CURRENT LAW
AND THAT IS PROPOSED FOR THE
COMMUNITY SOURCE BLOOD BANKS
NEEDS TO BE CONTINUED.
I'M FOR REASONS THAT WERE CLEAR
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND REMAIN
TODAY.
I'M ALSO HAD THE BILL WOULD
CHANGE.
THE LICENSING REQUIREMENT FROM A
PERSON QUALIFIED TO RUN A BLOOD
BANK TO A LICENSED VETERINARIAN
THAT IS BOTH A TOO STRINGENT
INTO ENGINE TO LENIENT IN THAT
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE A
VETERINARIAN TO RUN A BLOOD BANK.
AND JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE A
VETERINARIAN DOESN'T MEAN YOU
CAN'T RUN A BLOOD BANK.
SO WE THINK EXISTING LAWS PINE
AN EXISTING LAW ALSO REQUIRES
OVERSIGHT BY A LICENSED
VETERINARIAN SO-- HAVING IT RUN
BY A BY A LICENSED VETERINARIAN
IS DUPLICATIVE.
AND FINALLY.
THERE'S A PROVISION IN EXISTING
LAW THAT TALKS ABOUT THE MAXIMUM
LENGH OF TIME.
A DONATION IN THE BILL WOULD
CHANGE -- THE WORD OR TAKE AND
THAT PROVISION WAS PUT THERE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE TWO EXISTING
BLOOD BANKS ONE OF WHICH RELIES
UPON THE THE FIRST PROPOSITION.
EIGHT THEY TAKE.
A DONOR OR THEY TAKE DOGS FROM
THE GREYHOUND RACING INDUSTRY --
WHO DONATE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
BEFORE THEY -- OR TRANSFERRED
OWNERSHIP TO ANOTHER HOME WHERE
IS ANIMAL BLOOD BANK HAS ALWAYS
RESCUED ANIMALS -- AND NOW HAS
TO USE BRED ANIMALS BECAUSE OF
RESCUE ANIMALS ARE NO LONGER
AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT THOSE
ANIMALS DONATE WHILE THEY'RE
HEALTHY.
AND WHEN THEY'RE NOT HEALTHY
THEY CONTINUE ON AS PART OF THE
PACK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS.
OKAY -- TO THE AUTHOR COULD YOU
RESPOND FOR THE COMMITTEE TO THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE JUST RAISE AN
OPTION.
I THINK WE'VE GOT A MEETING
SCHEDULE LATER LATER THIS WEEK --
TODAY TO DISCUSS TO DISCUSS
THOSE ISSUES -- AND NUMBER THOSE
ISSUES I I THINK.
RE BE TOTALLY AMENABLE -- TO
NEED TO HAVE MORE DISCUSSIONS ON
THAT ON THAT.
ON THE ASPECT OF THE
CONFIDENTIALITY -- WE'RE NOT
RELEASING ANY PERSON'S NAME IS
JUST GONNA BE DATA ON ON ON ON
THE THE DOCKS THEMSELVES MEDICAL
DATA SO ON SO BUT WE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS YOU KNOW THIS
IS A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS.
AND THE WHOLE POINT OF THE BILL
IS NOT TO PUT ANYBODY OUT OF
BUSINESS AS MORE RADICAL
APPROACH BEING TAKEN OVER IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE.
BUT TO JUST.
TO INCREASE THE RATE LIABILITY
OF THESE BLOOD BANKS AND THEN
AGAIN AS MENTIONED BY THE DOCTOR
TO HAVE THESE.
HER DOGS YOU KNOW RAISED IN A
LOVING ENVIRONMENT SO IT'S A WIN
WIN FOR THE DOGS FOR THE
FAMILIES.
AND FOR THE RECIPIENTS OF THE OF
THE BLOOD DONATION SO YEAH WE'RE
GOOD GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND AND GET A BILL THAT
HOPEFULLY WE ALL CAN GET TO BUT
AND IT'S ABOUT RELIABLE.
SOURCE OF THE BLOOD -- ARE AT
AND PERHAPS YOU COULD CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MAYBE
FURTHER CLARIFYING A PERSON
QUALIFIED IN THE FIELD I THINK
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE TOTALLY OPEN
TO THAT OKAY.
I THINK WE'RE TOTALLY OPEN TO
THAT I THINK MOST OF THESE
THINGS WHAT WE WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO REACH AN ACCOMMODATION
ON OKAY THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND CIVIL THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GALGIANI HERE JOHNNY
HERE WILK HERE WILK HERE
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO HERE GLAZER.
HE WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
WITH A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB TWO ZERO TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED OR RE REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATORS GALGIANI AYE JOHNNY I
WILL HI WILK I HAVE A HERO.
CABALLERO AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
WE CAN [inaudible]
THE END.
CONGRATULATIONS WE WILL PUT THAT
BELONG CALL SO WE CAN ADD ON
MEMBERS AT THE END -- I SEE THE
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS HERE PLEASE.
WELCOME [inaudible]
WHAT A?
I SEE THAT YOU HAVE TO BILLS
BEFORE US THIS MORNING SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE DEALING WITH
CANNABIS MARKETING.
AND SB FOUR FORTY NINE DEALING
WITH PIERCE'S DISEASE.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER AND I
I ALWAYS -- LE BEING IN YOUR
COMMITTEE YOU RUN IT WELL AND
YOU WERE SO COLLABORATIVE AND IS
ONE TAKE MOM SAID THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR.
WELL AS OUR INCREDIBLE TEAM. FOR
THEIR HARD WORK HONESTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE I MADAM CHAIR THIS
LEGISLATION IS A TRUTH IN
LABELING TRANSPARENCY BILL.
THAT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IN THE
CURRENT LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR
COMPANIES TO USE THE NAMES OF
APPELLATIONS IN THE PRODUCTS IN
ADVERTISING AND IT FURTHER
CLARIFIES THE ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
CANNABIS IN CANADA PRODUCTS ON
THE GOLDEN STATE.
CURRENTLY IS YOUNG THOUGH IT IS
LEGAL FOR CANVAS PRODUCTS USING
NAME OF A CALIFORNIA COUNTY THE
PRODUCT'S LABELING ITS MARKETING
OR PACKAGING.
EVEN IF THE CANNABIS WAS DOT
RHONE IN THAT COUNTY BOARDS.
BUT THERE IS A LOOPHOLE UNDER
THE MEDICAL AND DON'T USE
CANNABIS REGULATION AND SAFETY
ACT THAT ALLOWS FOR THE LABELING
OF CANVAS PRODUCTS TO
MISREPRESENT THE NAME OF
APPELLATIONS.
THIS CAN MAKE CONSUMERS THINK
THAT THE PRODUCT THEIR
PURCHASING IS GROWN IN A
SPECIFIC REGION.
IN FACT IT'S NOT.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITIONS RD STATUTE.
ON IMPROPERLY USING COUNTY NAMES
FOR CANNABIS PRODUCTS DO INCLUDE
ANY SIMILAR SOUNDING NAME
APPELLATIONS THAT IS LIKELY TO
MISREPRESENT THE ORIGIN OF THE
PRODUCT.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT IF
PRODUCTS ARE LABELED IN WAYS
THAT LEAD CONSUMERS TO BELIEVE
THERE FROM CERTAIN AREAS.
THOSE PRODUCTS SHOULD IN FACT BE
FROM THOSE LOCATIONS.
SIMULATING LIES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY BEEN IN PLACE FOR
WINE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND AT
THE FEDERAL LEVELS FOR YEARS.
AND IT IS PROMOTED CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLARITY FOR
CUSTOMERS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN A
CONSUMER BUYS.
BUYING CALIFORNIA WINE THEY KNOW
THAT THE COUNTY BOARD GIN WHERE
THE GRADES HAVE BEEN HARVESTED
WHICH IS ALSO LISTED ON THE
LABEL.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE CLARIFIES THE
ORGANIC CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS
WELL HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
CANNABIS IN MANUFACTURED CANVAS
PRODUCTS IN POWER IN THE
INDUSTRY TO CERTIFY THEIR
PRODUCTS AS ORGANIC UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ONCE THE DEPARTMENT'S
COMPLETE THE REGULATIONS.
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'M GONNA TAKE
A MOMENT MAN CHAIR AND INDEED
HERE TO SAY THANK OF TERROR
CARVER.
OFTEN THE HUMBLE COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE WHO IS A TRAVELING FROM
FAR AND WIDE FOR THE PAST MANY
WEEKS ON THIS BILL IN OF COURSE
TO MISS HEARST.
REPRESENTS A REAL COUNTY
REPRESENT IS A CALIFORNIA WHO
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND AGAIN MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO BE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND REMARKS
AND FOR YOUR WITNESSES PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR REQUIRE --
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS TERRA CARVER AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE.
WE ARE A TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING WELL OVER TWO
HUNDRED LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
DUE TO FEDERAL SCHEDULING
CANNABIS INDUSTRY DOES NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE NATIONAL ORGANICS
PROGRAM ONLY THROUGH THE STATE
PROGRAM WILL WE BE ABLE TO
CREATE COMPATIBLE STANDARDS AND
CERTIFY AND MARKET -- CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCTS AS ORGANIC IN
ADDITION TO THE ORGANICS PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS TAKEN THE LEAD IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF APPELLATIONS OF
ORIGIN PROGRAM. FOR CANNABIS
WHICH IS ALSO A STANDARDS BASED
CERTIFIED DESIGNATION WHILE
APPELLATION OF ORIGIN HAS A
GLOBAL HISTORY THAT IS HUNDREDS
OF YEARS OLD CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ESTABLISHING THE FIRST SUCH
PROGRAM. FOR CANNABIS IN THE
WORLD.
THIS PROGRAM IS AN ESSENTIAL
TOOL FOR THE REGIONALMARKETING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF
LEGACY CANNABIS IN PRODUCING
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
THERE STRENGTHENING THE STANDARD
BASED MARKETING PROGRAMS FOR
LICENSE PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP IN PROTECTING
CONSUMERS PROTECTING AGAINST
COUNTERFEIT PRODUCTS ON THE
MARKET PLACE IN SECURING
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION.
AS A LEADER WITHIN THE EMERGING
GLOBAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
I'M NOT COUNTY AND INDEED ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IS WORLD RENOWNED FOR
CANNABIS FLOWER IN MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS.
AND WE TAKE GREAT.
CERTIFIED PRODUCT WITH VARIABLE
STANDARDS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
REMEMBERS JEANNE HERS HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE SEARS HE'S HAD A LONG
STANDING POLICY IN SUPPORT OF
APPELLATION.
VERIFICATION SYSTEMS FOR
CANNABIS AND MANY OF OUR A RURAL
COUNTY MEMBERS ARE -- USING THIS
AS A MARKETING STRATEGY FOR
THEIR OWN CANNABIS -- GROSS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP ACCOMPLISH --
THAT GOAL AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MADAM
CHAIR TUNING COLEMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF THE
MENDOCINO APPELLATIONS PROJECT.
AND THE MENDOCINO CANNABIS
ALLIANCE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL AND THANK CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR YOUR GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS YES THANK YOU CHAIR
GALGIANI MEMBERS HAD MALL HAS A
REPRESENTING SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX MEDIA.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL APPRECIATE
SENATOR REQUIRE WORKING ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPLEMENTATION
PROVISIONS OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CONCERNS. TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR CAPPIELLO.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BUT I WAS
WONDERING IF I COULD JUMP JOIN
HIM AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN EVERY
MAKES AN AMENDMENT.
AND I I WILL MOVE DEVELOP AT
WHAT TIME IT'S APPROPRIATE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
WELL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DO PASSING REFERRED OR
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GALGIANI
AYE GALGIANI AYE WILK.
WILK I HAVE A ZERO ZERO I GLAZER.
OKAY WE WILL GO AHEAD AND HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THAT BILL AND
THEN YOU HAVE YOUR NEXT BILL.
SB FOUR FORTY NINE DEALING WITH
PIERCE'S DISEASE.
YES MA'AM CHAIR READING CHAIR
WE'RE DEALING WITH A SENATOR
WILKES TWO FAVORITE SUBJECTS
CANNABIS AND WINE.
I KNOW.
DEPENDING ON WHAT DAY IT SO --
WILSON GOT AWKWARD.
ALL RIGHT -- THERE YOU GO.
BETTER CHAIR -- WE ARE HONORED
TO BE A TO PRISON AS BEFORE --
FORTY NINE AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA MAKES 81% OF ALL WINE
IN AMERICA.
AND WE ARE PROBABLY NOW THE
WORLD'S FOURTH LARA LEADING WINE
PRODUCER WE'RE HOME TO NEARLY
SIX THOUSAND ONE GREAT GROWERS
IN FORTY NINE AT A FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
ROLL WINE GRAPES AND YOU ARE NOW
GOING TO BE AN ACCOMPLISHED
JEOPARDY CHAMPION IF WE EVER
HAVE A SUBJECT ON CALIFORNIA
WINE ON THE BIG SHOW.
THE VITAL INDUSTRY SUPPORTS
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS JOBS
IN FAMILY FARM INCOMES TRULY.
A GENERATES TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE'S ECONOMY AND WHILE
WINE GRAPES CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH
TO OUR ECONOMY.
THEY ARE RISK TO A RANGE OF
DISEASES AND ONE OF THE MOST
DEADLY IS PIERCE'S DISEASE IT'S
KEEP OF KILLING VINES WITHIN TWO
YEARS.
PIERCE'S DISEASE IS SPREAD BY A
NASTY LITTLE **** CALLED THE
SHARPSHOOTER IN ONCE A BIND IS
INFECTED DISEASE WILL BLOCK THE
WATER SYSTEM.
OF THE PLANT THE FRUIT WILL
SHRIVEL IN BOTH THE LEAVES IN
THE FRUIT WILL DIE THERE'S STILL
NO KNOWN CURE FOR THE DISEASE
AND THE CHAIR WOMAN HAS BEEN.
A CHAMPION ON THIS ISSUE FOR
MANY YEARS.
AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL SB FOUR FORTY NINE EXTENDS
THE EXISTING PIERCE'S DISEASE
CONTROL PROGRAM THE TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TO CONTINUE IMPORTANT
RESEARCH EFFORTS TO COMBAT.
CAN TO COMBAT THIS DEVASTATING
DISEASE THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES
FUNDING GIVEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONDUCTING RESEARCH.
I IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE
FUNDING WILL NOT BE USED TOWARDS
INDIRECT TO OVERHEAD COSTS SUCH
AS FACILITIES OR ADMINISTRATIVE
OBLIGATIONS. TO SUPPORT RESEARCH
AND EFFORTS TO CONTROL THE
SPREAD OF PIERCE'S DISEASE WHICH
DOES MOVE FAST.
A CALIFORNIA CREATED THE
PIERCE'S DISEASE CONTROL PROGRAM
IN THE PIERCE'S DISEASE AND
GLASS SERVING SHARPSHOOTER BOARD
IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE PROGRAM IN
THE BORDER FUNDED THROUGH
FEDERAL INDUSTRY FINDS IN WINE
GRAPE GROWERS ASSESSMENTS.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE PASS THIS
BILL AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAVE TWO CHAMPIONS UP
FOR THIS ISSUE JACK WELCOME THE
MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND TO MY
LEFT.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA'S
OCEAN A WINE GRAPE WORST IN OF
COURSE KIND OF LACKEY FOR THE
WIND TO TOOT GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL -- IN
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND APPROPRIATE TIME
AND CHECK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND THE SENATE MCGUIRE -- JACK
WALK WITH A WALKER -- BY BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WHITE
GRAPE GROWERS.
THE MEMBERS IS COMMITTEE EITHER
IN THIS HOUSE OF YOUR OTHER
HOUSE HAVE SUPPORTED THIS
PROGRAM IN THE PAST AND WE'RE
GREAT VERY GRATEFUL. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S ENDORSEMENT OF THE
PROGRAM BOTH IN ITS ORIGINAL
FORM AND ITS EXPANSION A FEW
YEARS AGO WITHOUT THE STATE'S
PARTNERSHIP OR ABILITY TO SECURE
FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE LIMITED.
AND THE GROWERS WOULD NOT BE --
AS EXCITED ABOUT PARTICIPATING
IN THEIR ASSESSMENTS WITHOUT THE
STATE BEING A VIABLE AND HELPFUL
PARTNER SO WE AGREE TO
APPRECIATE CENTER REQUIRE
STEPPING UP IN CARE IN THIS BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS -- TIED LACKEY THE
ONE IS -- TO I THINK MR REQUIRED
A TREMENDOUS JOB OF PRESENTING
THAT BILL AND ACT PRISON ISSUE
SO I WILL JUST THNKING FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHAT OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
MELISSA WERNER ON BEHALF OF THE
<c.cyan>AMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA</c>
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS COMMENTS.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD I
WAS WORKING FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARBER MATTHEWS AT THE TIME WHEN
THIS WAS -- A NEWER PROBLEM TO
THE STATE AND RISKS --
FORTUNATELY THE STATE RESPONDED
AND HAD FUNDING IN THE BUDGET SO
THAT WE COULD CONTROL THIS AT
THAT TIME AND WE'VE BEEN
CONSISTENT AND CONTROLLING IT
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THE
PROBLEM THAT IT.
ABSOLUTE MINIMUM IN THE STATES
OF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
AND AT THIS POINT WITH THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL --
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND SIGN.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
SB FOUR FOUR NINE THE MOTION IS
DO PASSING RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GALGIANI
HI -- JOHNNY AYE WILK.
WILK I CABALLERO CALERO AYE
GLAZER.
CONGRATULATIONS WE'LL CALL THE
BILL.
MORE HOLD THE WORLD OPEN FOR YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MONEY [inaudible]
YOUR TURN
.
GOOD MORNING YOU'RE HERE PRESENT
SB SIX SIXTY SEVEN DEALING WITH
CANNABIS CULTIVATION AND COUNTY
AG COMMISSIONERS YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THE BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN ALLOWS
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER
TO INCLUDE CANNABIS AS AN
ADDENDUM TO THE COUNTY'S ANNUAL
AGRICULTURE REPORT.
BETTER KNOWN AS THE CROP REPORT.
THE DATA COLLECTED WOULD BE
ORGANIZED BY SPECIFIC CATEGORIES.
SOME COUNTIES ARE FINDING THAT
BECAUSE CANNABIS IS CURRENTLY
NOT INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT IT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION.
OF THE COUNTY'S AGRICULTURAL
CULTIVATION.
NORMALIZING CANNABIS AS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT WILL
ENCOURAGE UNLICENSED GROWERS TO
COME FORWARD AND BECOME
LEGITIMATE PERMITTED AND TAX
PAYING BUSINESSES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION IS
SUPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. TO THE
CURRENT BILL MAINLY DUE TO THE
PLACEMENT OF THIS PROVISION IN
THE FOOD IN AG CODE INSTEAD OF
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE.
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ORGANIZATION AND WILL KEEP
COMMITTEE STAFF INFORMED AS WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND FURTHER
AMEND THE BILL.
I HAVE WITH ME MONTEREY COUNTY
SUPERVISOR IN FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ALEJO AND
MONTEREY COUNTY AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONER HENRY GONZALEZ HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU WELCOME TO OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
MISTER LAIHO THANK YOU MANAGER
AND COLLEAGUES -- IT'S RARE THAT
I GET A CHANCE TO COME BACK TO
SACRAMENTO BUT IT'S GOOD TO BE
HERE TACK TO ME WITH MY GOOD
FRIEND THE CENTER BILL MONEY IN
A SIMPLER BILL FROM OUR COUNTY.
ARE COUNTIES UP COSPONSOR OF SB
SIX FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD GIVE
OUR COUNTIES AND OTHER COUNTIES
THE OPTION TO OF INCLUDING
CANNABIS PRODUCTION IN THEIR
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS CROP
REPORTS.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES A
COUNTY MONTEREY PRODUCES A
COUPLE HOURS ERECTED A CAVERNOUS --
GREENHOUSES SOUTH OF THE CITY
SALINAS IN GLOBAL COMPETITION
PARTICULARLY FROM LATIN AMERICA
DECIMATED THE MARKET.
DOWNTURN LEFT TRACKS OF THEY
CAN'T COLLAPSING STRUCTURES AND
PLAYED A ROLE IN PUSHING LOCAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES TO MORE THAN
11%.
NOW HOWEVER MANY OF THOSE VALLEY
GREENHOUSE ARE BLOOMING ONCE
AGAIN AS CANNABIS PRODUCTION
MOVES INTO MONTEREY COUNTY WHEN
THE MOST ABUNDANT AGRICULTURAL
AREAS IN THE WORLD.
EVEN BEFORE CANNABIS WAS
LEGALIZED.
MARIJUANA ENTREPRENEURS WAS
SEEKING OUT AGING AND
RETROFITTING GREENHOUSES IN
MARIN COUNTY.
IN ADDITION TO CULTIVATION MINOR
COUNTIES POLICE TO SERVE AS A
MAJOR AND CENTRALLY LOCATED CAM
IS PRODUCTION HUB TO SERVE THE
STATE'S METROPOLITAN AREAS THE
JUST SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES.
IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO
PRODUCE AND TRANSPORT.
CURLY MONTEREY COUNTY IS ALREADY
FOURTH IN STATE CULTIVATION
BEHIND SANTA BARBARA HUMBLED AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES BUT WE ARE
THE LARGEST ON CANNABIS NURSERY
PRODUCING COUNTY IN THE STATE
WITH SIXTY SIX PERMITTED US
SITES.
THE COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORTS
LEGITIMIZING IN NORMALIZING CAM
IS PRODUCTION AS A CONTRIBUTION
TO THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY AND
ALLOWING FOR CANNABIS TO BE
INCLUDING THE STATE'S ANNUAL
CROP REPORT.
I'M HIGHLIGHTED THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE CROP AND RELATED
PRODUCTION DATA INTO THE CROP
REPORT TO ALSO HELP MONTEREY AND
OTHER COUNTIES PROMOTE AND
BETTER MARKET THIS AGRICULTURAL
PORTFOLIO TO INVESTORS SEEKING.
TO BACK RESPONSIBLE OPERATIONS
THROUGH DIRECT FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
MONTEREY COUNTY IS AND CONTINUES
TO BE A LEADER IN THE PRODUCTION
OF CAT COMMERCIAL CANNABIS THE
STATE AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT
BILLING WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND AS STATED WE HAVE WE'RE
PRODUCTS WILL HAVE OUR AYE
COMMISSIONER THE FIRST LATINO
AYE COMMISSIONER MONTEREY COUNTY
WITH IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME.
PLEASE GOOD MORNING THE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS HENRY GONZALEZ AND I
SERVE AS AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER FOR THE COUNTY OF
MONTEREY.
EXISTING LAWS SAVAGES THAT THERE
BE A DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
IN EACH OF OUR COUNTIES.
UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER ONE OF
THE MANY MANDATE TO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER IS TO
COMPILE.
A AND TRANSMIT AN ANNUAL REPORT
THE CROP REPORT.
UP TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE REPORT IS
INCLUDED THE CONDITION A
CHRISTIAN PRODUCTION WITHIN OUR
RESPECTIVE COUNTIES SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN MONEY AND WOULD PROVIDE
THAT CANNABIS.
CAN BE INCLUDED IN ONE OF THE
MANY CROPS THAT WE REPORT.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL STATE THAT
IF A COUNTY CHOOSES TO INCLUDE
IN THEIR REPORT CANNABIS.
PRODUCTION A CAN BE CATEGORIZED
BY STATE CULTIVATOR LICENSE TYPE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SB
SIX FIFTY SEVEN PROPOSES AN
OPTIONAL REPORTING PROVISION
THEREFORE COUNTIES THAT CHOOSE
NOT TO REPORT.
DO NOT HAVE TO REPORT.
A CROP REPORTS ARE USED TO
SHOWCASE THE CONTRIBUTIONS.
OF AGRICULTURE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTIES.
AND POVIDE STATISTICAL DATA ON
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION THE
REPORT IS AN ANNUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE THE GROWERS
RANCHERS SHIPPERS AND THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THEM IN MAKING FARMING A
PRIORITY.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY AGRICULTURE
IS THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMIC
DRIVER.
UNDER CURRENT MONTEREY COUNTY
RATE REGULATIONS COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS OFFER.
OPERATORS CAN ONLY GROW IN
GREENHOUSES.
OR INDOOR FACILITIES IN CERTAIN
ZONING AREAS BY CONVERTING
EXISTING STRUCTURES.
THE EXISTING THEIR PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
THEY MAY NOT PLANT OUTDOOR OR
OTHERWISE UPSET.
THE COUNTY SIGNATURE FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY OF LEAF LETTUCE
STRAWBERRIES BROADLY HEAD
LETTUCE CELERY YOU CAN ACTUALLY
GO ON AND ON THERE'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT COMMODITIES
THAT WE GROW UP AND AND THIS
WOULD ADD TO OUR DIVERSITY.
A MONTEREY COUNTY ESTIMATES THAT
IT WILL SOON BE IN THE TOP FIVE
COUNTIES FOR CANNABIS
CULTIVATION THE COUNTY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS LEGITIMIZING CANNABIS
CULTIVATION.
AS A CONTRIBUTION TO THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND
ALLOWING FOR CANNABIS TO BE
INCLUDED IN HE STATE'S ANNUAL
CROP REPORT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARD
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS PORK.
TERRA CARVER HIGH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WHOLE COUNTY
GROWERS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TUNING HOME AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MENACING
APPELLATIONS PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS.
ARE GOOD MORNING TO REMEMBER
STILL RICH WITH A CALIFORNIA
FIRM HERE WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
OFFICIALLY ON THE BILL.
I'M ISN'T REFLECTED IN THE
RECORD BUT OUR CONCERN IS
PREDICATED ON BLURRING THE LINES
BETWEEN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS ARE WE
CERTAINLY CAN OBJECT TO THE
CONCEPT OF COLLECTING
INFORMATION ON CAMPUS COVER
PORTING THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY. TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT AND FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THAT
WITHIN THEIR ECONOMIC PORTFOLIO
OF THEIR COUNTY.
BUT WE DON'T WE DO SEE IT A
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT FROM
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION I'M I
THINK BEYOND THAT THAT WE HAVE
HAD GREAT CONVERSATIONS WITH
CENTER MONNING A STAFF AND AND
ADD TO THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL --
AND WITH SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
AMENDMENTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING OPPOSITION THE FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND TO THE AUTHOR DID
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO HER
COMMENTS WELL I'M.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY IN IN IN
MY OPENING STATEMENT I DID
INDICATE THE CONCERN SEEMS TO
FOCUS ON WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE
IN THE FOOD NAG CODE OR BMP.
IT WAS TOO LATE TO PROPOSE
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS HEARING SO
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WHERE --
WORKING IN THAT DIRECTION A GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS SENATOR CAPPIELLO.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION DO YOU
KNOW -- IF THE NON EDIBLE GROWN
PRODUCE DISH SHOWS UP IN THE ACT
IN THE ACT REPORT.
AND I'M THINKING FLOWERS AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS LISTEN THE
A COMMISSIONER RESPOND TO THAT.
THE ANNUAL PROPER OR DOESN'T
INCLUDE NON EDIBLE RIGHT YES YES
WE INCLUDE.
UP FOR CUT FLOWERS A POTTED
PLANTS.
HONEY A WAX -- OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE NOT NON EDIBLE IN ARE THOSE
IN THE BMP COTERIE THEY PART OF
THE THE ECHO.
ECHO [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES I AM [inaudible]
QUESTION -- GOOD OKAY.
THANK YOU MY CLOTHES YOU'VE
HEARD IT I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE IN
A REMINDER THIS IS VOLUNTARY.
THE COUNTY DECIDES IF IT WANTS
TO CREATE AN ADDENDUM TO THE
CROP REPORT.
RESPECT SLASH FEAR AYE VOTE.
THE BILL THE MOTION OF THE BILL
WE HAVE A MOTION AND WILL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GALGIANI AYE JOHNNY I
WILL.
WILL DIE CABALLERO AYE OF AERO
AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER II.
CONGRATULATIONS FABOLOUS OUT.
WE ARE THE ONE HE AND WE WILL
NOW LIVE THE CALL ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB TWO OH TWO BY SENATOR
WILK.
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO WELL THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB TWO ZERO TWO TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY SENATOR
GLAZERS.
GLAZER HI THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE WILL OPEN UP ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE VOTERS.
THREE TO ZERO SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
DO PASSING RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER RIGHT.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AND FINALLY I AM THREE AS BEFORE
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO SB FOUR
FOUR NINE TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE THAT BILL IS OUT AND
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE US TODAY THANK YOU